i want to express my sincere  appreciation to academy the student  academia award was one of my dreams when  i first came to this country to study  animation  i want to say thank you to my team and  all the hidden advisors john and paul  taya juju and you  i was truly lucky to have you all in my  journey in this country  and i do appreciate all the the  kellart's experimental animation faculty  members the paul vaster and maureen  salud marine furnace pia boar and  alexander steadward and lately and my  dear classmates  these amazing teachers and great artists  they told me the value and meaning of  the filmmaking  my father mother and the brother in  korea i miss you all i cannot explain  how much i appreciate you thank you so  much for your endless support and trust  in my work and my life  and lastly bully  a great sound designer and my forever  sound designer thanks a lot every time  i'm depressed and you tell me i'm the  best on this earth then you're the best  in my mind  you